as things heat up between Kylie Jenner
and Timothy chalamet a source tells E.T
her ex Travis Scott is not thrilled
about it I don't think we really wanted
anyone else's opinion back in April ET
learned that the beauty Mogul and the
actor are dating now a source explains
that they are casually seeing each other
and trying to keep it low-key they are
becoming more comfortable with each
other but Kylie wants to take things day
by day and see where it goes growing up
in front of the spotlight is definitely
hard but there's so many blessings that
come along with it too so what does
Kylie's famous fam think of all that our
source says the cargeners think it's
great that Kylie is doing her thing and
they're supportive but not everyone is
here for it oursource claims her ex
doesn't love that Kylie is moving on
Kylie and Travis share two children
together a five-year-old daughter stormy
and a one-year-old son air they've been
on and off for years their latest break
confirmed by a source in January who
told ET Kylie and Travis live different
lives Kylie's more of a homebody well
Travis likes to go out and party and
that's been a big issue
then in March A source told ET that
Kylie was trying to stay positive and
wanted things with Travis to remain
drama free and today our source says
that Kylie and Travis are still cordial
they are focused on co-parenting and
being the best mom and dad they can be
as for Timothy our source says he loves
that Kylie is such a Hands-On mom and
boss he appreciates her confidence and
thinks she's incredibly beautiful
neither one has addressed the romance
publicly and they haven't stepped out in
an official way but fans are hopeful
we'll learn more about their budding
Romance when season three of Hulu's the
Kardashians premieres May 25th I don't
want my daughter to do the things I did
I wish I'd never touched anything to
begin with the episodes are more a
little bit documentary style you have a
real insight into what's really
happening behind the scenes
foreign